tu le retrouver tu sais où elle est
alors on n'a qu'à appeler la police et
régleront le problème
bruce faut surtout pas prévenir les
flics wendy là illégalement
s'il la trouve hilarant deux roues à
madagascar en plus nhân a demandé que ce
soit moi qui m'en occupe ça doit être
moi elle était très spécifique sur ce
point là
faut qu on entre par effraction ce soir
t'es sérieux
tu veux lutter
évidemment à a
lee avez vous été diagnostiqué
schizophrène il ya dix ans je veux vivre
une vie normale
c'est tout ce que je veux qu'est ce qui
est normal et qu'est ce qui n'est pas
annie pourre côté là
suivent des précisions
et ça dure depuis pas mal de temps
j'ai confiance en ce traitement et je
pense que nous pouvons tous être guéri
j'ai besoin d'être guidé ses options non
je trouve pas ça début
j'ai trouvé
ou est-ce vous qui devient croisé mon
chemin
à chaque fois que je laissais part il
trouve le moyen de se rejoindre il se
peut que ces deux là qu'une connexion
cosmique
on était juste deux êtres
qui vaille est là sur l'autre
[Musique]
où